سجن سعد المجرد بتهمه الاغتصاب يقسم الناس
بين محتفلين بتحقق العداله ومدافعين عن
سعد وبيع جواز سفر السادات يفجر ازمه في
مصر واجدد عجائب الحوثي تحذير من ادويه
اجنبيه بالنفط اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد سبع سنوات من رفع القضيه وسبع ساعات
متواصله من المداولات يوم الجمعه قضت
محكمه الجنايات الفرنسيه بالسجن ست سنوات
بحق المغني المغربي سعد المجرد وادانت
بتهمه الاغتصاب اللي كانت رفعتها المدعي
عليه لورا في 2016 وشافت المحكمه في
الادله ووصف المدعي عليه ما هو ثابت ودقيق
وشافت في كلام سعد لمجرد العكس وقالت انه
اقوال متغيره ومتبدله وعليه صدر الحكم
بالسجن ومنعه من دخول فرنسا بعدها خمس
سنوات والحكم قابل للاستئناف خلال عشره
ايام للي مو متابعه التفاصيل ساعد اولا
روايتهم متفقه في الجزء الاول بس المتعلق
بانه ملتقوا في نايت كلوب رجعت معه على
الاوتيل رقصوه تبادل القبل لكن بعدها عاد
بتختلف روايتهم هي بتقول انه تهجم عليها
جبرها تخلع ملابسها ضربها لمن رفضته
وبعدين اغتصبها وبتقول انه كان تحت تاثير
والمخدرات وهو بينفو تماما وهو بينفي
تماما انه صارت علاقه جنسيه بينه وبين
لورا وبيقول انه هي كمان كانت تحت تاثير
الكحول وانها كانت تبغى منه فلوس ويبدو
غلطت وانه ضربها بس علشان يدافع عن نفسه
لمجرد قيل انه في المحكمه بدا شاحب وما
كان في تعابير على وجهه ساعه الحكم اما
لورا فبكيه وحضنت والدتها وقالت انه حطوا
القيود في يده واخذوا ومن وقت الحكم وحتى
قبلها كمان من وقت مثول سعد امام المحكمه
والموضوع ترند ومتصدر عربيه وبعيدا يعني
عن الصراع بين سعد اولورا داخل المحكمه
فقضيه سعد عامله صراع من نوع ثاني تماما
برا ففي وقت ناس كثيره احتفلت بالحكم
وساعدت بانه في شخص مغتصب اخذ جزاته
بالقانون في ناس كثير شايف فتوه مظلوم
وبتدافع عنه وكثير من هؤلاء من المشاهير
فنانين ممثلين مطربين اعلاميين وهبوا لدعم
سعد والتضامن مع كثار بيقولوا مظلوم
وبعضهم حتى بيقول بكل صراحه انه لو يعني
لو ابني وغلط ايش اعمل معه ما راح ادمر
مستقبله وانه لازم نوقف جنبه
طيب الكثير من المتضامنين معه سعد جالسين
بيهاجموا لنا نحن شخصين في تفاعلكم
وشايفيننا متحملين ضد صعد لمجرد او عندنا
شيء ضده شخصيا او جزء من مؤامره عليه
للعلم يعني ما حد بينكر موهبه سعد ولا
فنون لكن هنا لازم ناخذ موقف ونوضح ولا
يوم في تفاعلكم كنا نحنا طرف في هذه
القضيه او غطينا اي شيء يتعلق من باب
الراي او وجهه نظرنا كله كان دوما كلام
عما هو امام القضاء او النظر في وصدر
الحكم في كمان احنا بنتكلم تحديدا على
الشخص ودين بالقضاء ورغم ذلك كل مره
تكلمنا في الموضوع عدنا وزدنا انه سعد
المجرد متى ما يحب له حق الرد ولليوم
بناكد على هذا الكلام من جديد لكن اسمحوا
لنا لمن يتعلق الامر بالاغتصاب والاعتداء
الجنسي ومو مره بالاكثر من مره هذه لازم
نذكرها نذكر فيها ونبولها مو مره اكثر من
مره ولمن يكون الشخص مدان بالا لا بل وصدر
ضده حكم قضائي ايضا هنا الموضوع ما فيه
حياد هنا الوصفه الوحيد والدقيق هو انه
هذا الشخص مغتصب ودين بالقانون وحكم
بالقانون ايضا وفي كمان ضحايا ما نقدر
نتجاهل ماساتهم وكانه اللي مروا فيه مو
مهم هل العموم يوم ما يستانف المجرد او
يتحاكم في قضيه اخرى ويطلع براءه حنكون
ايضا اول مليان نتناول الموضوع بس اقتضى
التنويه في هذا الموضوع وحنكمل كلامنا مع
الصحفيه المتابعه للقضيه حنان عبد الله
اللي بتنضم الينا من باريس اهلا فيك معانا
حنان انا عارفه انه انت تعرضتي لكثير ايضا
من الهجوم خصوصا بعد المره الماضيه لما
انبهرتي معانا وتحدثنا عن القضيه اول شيء
خليني ابتدي معاكي هل عندك اي تفاصيل عن
موضوع الاستئناف او القضيه نفسها
اهلا ساره كما قلت يعني هناك حق الرد
بالنسبه لسعد ونعود لموضوع الاستئناف اكيد
هناك اجراءات في طور يعني العمل عليها من
طرف المحامين لطلب استئناف هذا الحكم خلال
عنده يعني تقريبا عشره ايام قبل يعني
بعدها سيكون حسب هذه القرارات المحكمه هذا
من جهه هناك قضيه تنتظره في محكمه
الجنايات بالجنوب الفرنسي بمنطقه حيث
سنتروبي وحيث شابه فرنسيه ايضا تقول بانه
اعتدى عليها جنسيا تفاصيل هذه القضيه ايضا
وهذه المحاكمه غير معروفه ولكننا سننتظر
الكلمه القضاء في هذا الاطار يعني حتى لو
خلاص انه مثلا تم الاستئناف وتاكد الحكم
هذا او ما تم الاستئناف وخلاص ثبت هذا
الحكم لسه امامه قضيه اخرى قد تزيد عليه
سنوات اضافيه يعني نحن بنقول
اكيد اكيد ساره هذه يعني الحكم الذي بدت
في هذه القضيه التي ننتظرها منذ سبع سنوات
تقريبا لن يساهم في تسهيل الامور بالنسبه
للمحاكمه المقبله لانه فيها ايضا اعتداء
جنسي بمعنى انه هذه الكلمه تتكرر منذ
سنوات للاسف الشديد في مشوار سعد المجرد
الفني بمعنى اعتداء وتعنيف اعتداء وتعنيف
كان في امريكا ان كان في بلجيكا ان كان في
المغرب ان كان في فرنسا هذا ليس تحامل
القضاء قال كلمته في هذا الاطار ونحن لم
نقم الا بنقل ما قاله القضاء للعالم
العربي حتى تكون هناك صوره واضحه لانه
هناك تضليل للاسف اعلامي على السوشيال
ميديا حول المعلومات يعني هناك ما تقوله
المحكمه وما يتناقله الصحفي المحترف وهناك
ما تتناقله السوشيال ميديا وهذا ما جعل
هنا هذه الحرب يعني
الناس تقول انه ما في حكم من المحكمه ما
في ادانا ما في ادانا ما في ادانه الان
لما جات الادانه صاروا بيقولوا لا مؤامره
عليه لانه عربي او لانه نجم او ما الى ذلك
كيف بتردي على هذا الكلام من ناحيه انه
انت متابعه لقضايا يعني
ساره انا كامراه بكل بساطه لا يمكن ان
ادعم قضيه كهذه انا لا اتحدث عن سعد
الانسان الذي اعرفه استضفت في برنامج
مرتين التقيت به اعرف الوالده والوالد
متابعيهم يعني متابعاهم واعرفهم منذ الصغر
انا اشتغلت في المغرب كصحفيه وكنت متابعه
لمشوار سعد المجرد الفني هذا لا يعفيني من
انني كامراه يمكن ان اشفق عليه لانه وضع
نفسه في هذه الورطه وبانه كان يعلم بانو
تحت تاثير المخدرات هو بيصير عنيف ويصبح
شخصا اخر ولا يتمالك نفسه ولا يتحكم في
تصرفاته لما تكون انت انسان او لما تكون
انت فنان معروف وتمثل بلد كما قلت في
السابق كالمغرب فعليك ان تتفادى مثل هذه
الامور وانا كامراه بحكم ان هناك امراه في
هذه القضيه ربما اليوم نتحدث عن سعد
المجرد كرجل ونقول عن لغه بانه هي التي
ذهبت وهي التي قامت وهي وهي ونحن نسينا
بان هذه الفتاه كان في عمرها سنه والقضاء
الفرنسي يتعامل بنوع من يعني خصوصيه كبيره
جدا بالنسبه له فتاه في العشرين لا تعرف
شيء عندما تعنف تعنف عندما تغتصب تغتصب
والقضاء صارم نعود ونقولها عندما تكون
امراه في هذا الاطار ونحن نساء في العالم
العربي هناك قضايا اغتصاب وتعنيف هناك
نساء يعانين من هذا الاطار من هذا الامر
هناك اطفال يشاهدون السوشيال ميديا
ويشاهدون الاعلام لا يمكن ان اكون اليوم
انا كامراه يعني مسانده لقضيه وليس لسعد
هذا النوع من القضايا ولا يمكن ان اقول
لسعد سعد انت ابن بلدي وانت مغربي مثلي
وانا معك لا لا يمكن هناك امراه يعني محور
الكلام امراه تعرضت للعنف لا يمكن
الان انت بتلمحي كثير لكثير من التغريدات
اللي كتبوها مشاهير وتحدثوا فيها عن دعمهم
لسعد وقالوا سعد انه يعني عربي سعد نجم
كبير سعد اخونا سعد صديقنا لابد ان نقف
بجانبه وفي تجاهل تام للضحيه في هذه
القضيه تحديدا او غيرها
صحيح هناك تجاهل لما عاشته لغه خلال هذه
السنوات اضطهاد نفسي اضطراب نفسي متابعه
نفسيه
الامر معكوس لو كانت
الضحيه هي اللي مثلا فتاه عربيه او نجمه
او او او
هي اللي قامت بهذا لو انعكست الايه لو
كانت هي اللي قريبتنا لو كانت اختنا لو
كان كذا كيف كان حيكون موقفنا من اللي
اعتدى عليها
عندما تكون امراه وفتاه وبكل بساطه نساء
في قلب هذا النوع من القضايا فلا يمكن
لامراه الا ان تتضامن او بالاحرى ان تتفهم
وضع المراه في هذا الاطار يمكن ان نشفق
على سعد ولكن لا يمكن ان نتضامن معه
كاعلاميين مثلا انا اقول لاننا نمثل
واجهات اعلاميه هذه الواجهات هي تقوم بنوع
من التوعيه في دولنا العربيه وهذا شيء مهم
جدا اذا اردنا ان نتطرق لموضوع سعد فيجب
ان يكون الشخص حكيم وعقلاني ومنطقي في
تعامله مع هذه القضيه الانسان اخطا وكل
شخص منا يمكن ان يخطئ ولا يمكن ان نتضامن
مع ملفات من هذا النوع فقط لانه فيها رجل
وامراه والقانون قال كلمته في هذا الاطار
ولم يتبلى شخص على سعد يعني بهذا المعنى
البسيط طيب على العموم احنا حنتابع طبعا
الموضوع ونشوف تفاصيل
الاستئناف اذا في استئناف وتفاصيل القضيه
الاخرى تصدق يعني حنان صار لنا سبع سنين
ونحن بنتابع هذا الملف عده السنين الجاريه
على العموم بشكرك جدا على وجودك معانا
وعلى هذه المعلومات كانت معنا من باريس
الصحفيه المتابعه للقضيه حنان عبد الله
شكرا لك
من امس جواز سفر الرئيس المصري الراحل
انور السادات متصدر الاخبار والعناوين من
بعد ما شافوا الناس صوره الجواز وهو معروض
على موقع مزادات هاريج الامريكي وتم بيعه
في المزاد العلني هناك الناس من بعد ما
شافت صور الجواز انصدمت في حاله جدل كبير
وصارت ازمه نقدر نسميها ازمه جواز سفر
السادات فالناس صارت تتساءل كيف وصل
الجواز لامريكا وكيف بيتم بيعوف مزاد علني
ومين اللي مسؤول عن هذا الشيء وطبعا نفس
هذه الاسئله طرحوها عائله السادات اللي ما
اختلفت رده فعلهم كمان على الموضوع عن
الناس وكمان نتفاجئوا باللي شافوه
واعتبروا اهانه للعائله وللشعب المصري ككل
وطالب السلطات المصريه بمحاسبه المتورطين
والمسؤولين وعلى فكره اللي بيفتح موقع
المزاد الرسمي بيشوف صور جواز انور
السادات مكتوب انه نباع في 22 فبراير
مقابل 74 الف دولار او 47 الف او عفوا 47
الف دولار والنص وما زالت الناس بتزايد
عليه عشان تشتريه من اللي اشتراه بالسبعه
واربعين الف والمبلغ الان في المزايده
تخطى 71 الف
طيب على فكره جواز سفر السادات اللي تم
اصداره في 19 مارس سنه 74 وضل ساري
المفعول حتى 18 مارس 81 ومكتوب عليه
بالذهب باللغتين العربيه والفرنسيه
جمهوريه مصر العربيه جواز سفر دبلوماسي
اسره الراحل مثلها مثل كثير من الناس
بتسال كيف وصل جواز سفر السادات لموقع
المزادات هذا خاصه مقتنيات الرئيس الراحل
موجوده فقط هي عند اسرته يا اما في متحف
ميتابولكوم والقريه الفرعونيه ومكتبه
الاسكندريه مكتبه الاسكندريه على فكره ردت
وقالت انه هي عندها صحيح مقتنيات للسادات
استلمتها من زوجته الراحله جيهان لكنها
كانت
عباره الاوسمه والنياشين والسيوف والدروع
والبدله الشهيره اللي كان بيرتديها وقت
اغتياله في حادث المنصه وبعد الوثائق اللي
كتبها ايضا بخط يده وانه ما كان في ابدا
جواز سفر بين المقتنيات اللي عندهم ولكن
اللي اثار الجدل اكثر هو انه متحف الساده
الموجود في مكتبه الاسكندريه كان نشر في
2018 على صفحه الفيسبوك صور لجواز سفر
الرئيس الراحل وتم حذف المنشور مؤخرا من
على الصفحه
قلب من جديد عجائب وغرائب الحوثيين
واتباعهم مسلسل لا ينتهي وجديد اليوم
محاضر من قيادي الحوثيين واقف في محاضره
وقدام كمبيوتر واضح قدامه مليان حضور كمان
وبيحذر من الادويه الاجنبيه اللي قال انه
فيها نفط بترول وانه الهدف منا القضاء على
اليمنيين والعالم كمان
اي واحد يكتب عسل في امريكا وفي العالم
الكامل يحبس فورا اللي قال الله عن الشباب
والقران اصبح تخلف
ويعني ويحبس اللي يكتبه
اليهود اصبحت يطب الرائج تم ترشيخ طب
الادويه الكيميائيه مصنوعه من السماك
بعد ندخل كل مصنوع من النفط يقول له اشرب
قاس بترول ايش فيك
هكذا وجملها وحط عليها هذا اعلامي اصبحت
مقبوله ولا هو بترول في غلاف ماده
كيميائيه
وصلت الحياه هكذا
في المحاضره في القاعه هذه تكلم محمد شاري
واعتبر الفيديو في اخر محاضره ان شاء الله
في الجوله الخامسه عشر في القاعه هذي في
المكان هذاك انه كان حبه حق الضغط والسكر
والكوليسترول والكبد والدهون والاشياء
عجيبه
ولا حبه
ولا حبه بدون علاجات
شيء عجيب يعني بذمتكم هل طبيعي اللي
سمعناه بيتكلم بكل جديه كمان يعني الرجال
بيتكلم عن مؤامره ادواتها ادويه الضغط
والسكر وغيرها وسماها مصنوعات بتروليه
يهوديه مليانه سموم لاهداف اليمنيين
والعالم اجمع وعرض صور كمان يعني وقال لك
هذا سبب زياده الامراض في العالم التصريح
متداول بشكل واسع وصاير حديث الساعه او
خلينا ادق يعني عشان نكون دقيقين مسخره
الساعه
التصريح صحيح من جديد عجائب وخرافات
الحوثيين لكن للاسف مو الاول ولا الوحيد
وابشركم التصريح متداول اليوم لكنه يعودنا
ندوه من كم يوم عنوانها خطوره اللقاحات
على البشريه حضرها قيادات الميليشيا وعلى
راسهم رئيس حكومه الحوثيين غير المعترف
بها دوليا عبد العزيز بن حبتور ووزير
الصحه طه المتوكل مدير مكتب زعيم المليشيا
كمان والكلمات في الندوه ركزت على انه
الطب الحديث واللقاحات عباره عن مؤامره
عدوانيه كل هذا في الوقت اللي بتشير فيه
التقارير والبيانات الانتشار ملحوظ
للادويه والاوبئه في مناطق سيطرتهم لانه
من محاربتهم طبعا لحملات التطعيم مثل
الحصبه والشلال ويعني خلاص دخلوا الان
مرحله التفشي يعني
[موسيقى]
البذور هي اصغر دول امريكا الوسطى لكن مع
هذا فهي من اعلى الدول العالم في معدلات
الجريمه ورقم واحد على العالم في معدلات
جرائم القتل وهي من اخطر الدول ونسبه
الجريمه في عاليه جدا والاف والاف السكان
اعضاء في عصابات ولما نجيب بوكل جاء رئيس
في 2019 وعد بحرب على الجريمه المنظمه
وانه يخلص البذور اكثر دول امريكا الوسطى
امانا ويبدو انه شغال على خطته فمن وقتها
وشغال الحملات الامنيه ضدهم واعتقل للان
64 الف من اعضاء العصابات هذه وبنى سجن
سمي بمركز سجن الارهاب هذا سجن عملاق رح
يجير اكثر من 40 الف سجين ومن كم يوم نقل
السجن اول 2000 عضو من اعضاء العصابات في
مشهد حقيقه الفيديوهات والصور منه كانها
طالعه من فيلم اكشن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شفت التنظيم مع الموسيقى مع اشكال
المجرمين كده حافيين بالتاتوهات الكثيره
المخيفه وحلقين راسها ورجولهم مربطه يعني
كده فعليا مثل الافلام مشاهدين احنا وصلنا
لنهايه حلقتنا لليوم انا عدوه غدا ان شاء
الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]